In the example shown here, remember we
talked about a feature space that may be
four by four by four for RGB?
Well they did 16 by 16 by 16, and
then they manually selected
a target on the first frame.
So you can see here that, see this
ellipse that's been put down here,
and this ellipse that's
been put down there?
They, they specified that in advance and
they said, go, and
that one starts going, and I guess they
go here, and that one starts going.
And I want you to notice,
whoops let's get rid of the,
how well those mean shift models
stick to the players, okay?
The average number of
iterations was only four,
that is from one frame to another,
they had to move,
do the mean shift thing four
times to track the density.
They also worried about scale, in terms
of looking at how the the scale changed.